نبقى اذا في جده معلم هناك مراسله صباح
العربيه حنان البخاري حنان يسعد صباحك انا
عندي فضول اعرف شو السبب ولماذا يستهوي
دكتوره عبير اقتناء
مجسمات السياره
يا صباح الخير نادين طبعا الكثير من
الاشخاص ينادينا اليوم عندهم حب وشغف
لامتلاك انواع معينه من السيارات بس
ضيفتنا اليوم دكتوره عبير عندها حب والشغف
شرف من نوع اخر لمجسمات هذه السيارات
الاصليه نتعرف اكثر عن هذا الموضوع تنضم
معي الدكتور عبير وتكلمنا اكثر عن هوايه
تجميع واقتناء هذه المجسمات للسيارات
الاصليه صباح الخير دكتوره عبير في
البدايه لو تعرفينا اكثر عن بدايه شغفك في
المجسمات الاصليه للسيارات وكيف اصبح
هوايه الان لديك همم هو في البدايه طبعا
عن طريق الصدفه بحث يعني انا كنت بدي
اشتري سياره معينه نوف اخواني ما رضيوا لي
انه لا دي احسن وكده يعني
لما رحت مكان العاب
اللي جاءت مجسم السياره اللي انا ما
اشتريت على ارض الواقع
فلقيتها فاشتريتها بعدين رحت البيت قلت طب
خليني اجيب السياره اللي اشتريتها بعدين
خليني اجيب سيره اخوي اخوي الثاني ابوي و
بعدين ما شاء الله امتلكتي كل هذا العدد
تقريبا كم المجسم للسيارات
ومقاسات مختلفه واحده 64 وواحد همم 43
واحد 18
24 طيب بالنسبه للمجسمات هذه مثلا يعني من
فين بتقنيها تسافري بتروح عشان بس قطعه
معينه او سياره من نوع معين هو الاقتناء
ده عاده احنا بنجيبه من الاسواق تمام لكن
احنا عندنا اليوم في بائعين سعوديين
موجودين بيبيعوا وبيتقام مزادات اون لاين
اه بنشتري من هنا يعني وفي السفر لما اكون
مسافره
فبناخذها يعني نبحث انا اول ما اوصل اي
بلد اكتب
اول حاجه اسويها تقريبا كيف تتراوح اسعار
المجسمات والله تختلف حسب مقاس المجسم
يختلف حسب
الشركه اللي بتصنع المجسم فخلينا نقول
يعني تبدا من 299 وتوصل 99 ريال سعودي
ريال
طيب حنان
حنان انا عندي سؤال لعبير تساليها شو اكتر
مجسم هيك قريب على قلبها يعني بتحس انه
هذا المجسم هو السياره المفضله عندها
طيب عبير ايش افضل او اقرب مجسم سياره
عندك هو قريب لقلبك
يعني كل مجسمات قريبه على قلبي لكن انا
كثير تعبت مجموعه مجسمات السيارات
كان كل سنه يغير اللون
تعتبر ايه والشركه اساسا خلاص وقفت تقريبا
يعني هذه اتوقع قيمتها السوقيه الان يمكن
عاليه بما انها يعني وقفوها في السوق هي
الارض الواقعه توقفت لكن كم مجسمات ذحين
بدات تظهر لكن مثلا المجسمات اللي هي تقدر
تقولي بندرتها تغلس سعرها يعني المجسمات
اللي تيجي هنا في المجسم
لمبرجيني رسومات تيجي مع كل مجسم شهاده
الشهاده
فهنا لما يخلص ال2 مجسم كلهم
في حاجه
اساسا من يوم تصنيعه
حنان وعبير نشكركم عقبال ما يتحولوا
السيارات الى معرض على ارض الواقع سيارات
تعمل ونثير بها شكرا لكما من جده مراسله
صباح العربيه احلى البخاري